Whether they feature shocking twists or important
character developments, these sequel and prequel
moments made it impossible for us to watch our
favorite movies and shows the same way again.
It's safe to say that the truth about Darth
Vader — that he used to be Anakin Skywalker — is
no longer much of a spoiler, but it sure was
back in 1980. It's probably the most famous
twist in sci-fi history — and it wasn't even
in the filmmakers' original plans. Judging by
earlier versions of the script, George Lucas had
initially intended for Darth Vader and Anakin to
be two separate characters. The idea didn't even
occur to him until he was working on "The Empire
Strikes Back" — and the twist was originally
proposed as a joke, according to Marcia Lucas.
Yet amazingly, so many things from the original
movie make sense in retrospect. In fact,
fans can rewatch the scene from "A New
Hope" where Obi-Wan tells Luke about Anakin,
and find several clues that suggest the old master
wasn't telling the whole truth — even if they were
purely coincidental. When Obi-Wan tells Luke
about Uncle Owen's relationship with Anakin,
his delivery suggests that he might
be hiding something important.
"He didn't hold with your father's ideals, thought
he should've stayed here and not gotten involved."
Likewise, when Luke asks how his father died,
Obi-Wan pauses noticeably before answering. He
is technically lying when he tells Luke that
Vader "betrayed and murdered" Anakin — but if
you want to be more generous, you could say
that Obi-Wan is simply being metaphorical.
Since the beginning of the MCU, one thing has
seemed certain: SHIELD is on the side of the
good guys. After all, the organization
assembled the Avengers and consistently
worked against malevolent villains like
Loki and the evil HYDRA organization.
However, "Captain America: The Winter Soldier"
changed all that, as Steve Rogers discovers
that SHIELD and HYDRA have become one and the
same. Since the events of the first "Captain
America" movie, HYDRA has slowly infiltrated
the ranks of SHIELD — and they're hijacking
SHIELD's weapons and resources to carry out its
agenda. The sequel forces Captain America to
begin questioning authority and reexamine his
assumptions about right and wrong. Likewise,
it made Marvel fans feel a little guilty for
cheering at SHIELD's previous victories. Fans
will realize with horror that HYDRA must have
been working behind the scenes the whole time,
even during the Battle of
New York in "The Avengers."
"HYDRA grew right under your
nose, and nobody noticed."
"Why do you think we're meeting
in this cave? I noticed."
"How many paid the price before you did?"
It's also worth noting that "Captain America: The
Winter Soldier" set an entirely new precedent for
the MCU. Fans no longer had to wait for the
next Avengers movie to see plot points that
would have a major impact on other Marvel films.
This sequel proved that the events of one solo
movie could ripple outward to affect the entire
MCU — something we've seen many times since.
In "Finding Nemo," Dory's short-term memory
loss is pretty much just a running gag. Sure,
it moves the plot forward and helps
Marlin become a better parent,
but it's still mostly played for laughs.
Upon watching "Finding Dory," though,
fans will discover that the lovable blue
tang has her own tragic backstory to tell.
"Finding Dory" shows how much of a nightmare
it can be to live in constant fear that you'll
forget about the people you love. Viewers
can feel the pain of Dory's parents as they
worry about how their daughter will be able to
take care of herself — and for the first time,
audiences know what it's like to see the
world through Dory's eyes. In particular,
the montage at the beginning of the movie,
which shows young Dory growing up alone,
cements to viewers how little they truly
understood Dory in the first movie.
These moments from "Finding Dory" add a
whole new layer to "Finding Nemo" if you
watch it again. Not only do we learn the
origins of her "Just Keep Swimming" song,
but her monologue in which she begs Marlin not
to leave her becomes even more poignant when
you realize just how many people
have left Dory before. Likewise,
some of the jokes from the first film
will take on a much sadder undertone.
"I forget things almost instantly.
It runs in my family. Well,
at least I think it does. Uh… hm. Where are they?"
Fans who loved the faithful android
Bishop in "Aliens" are undoubtedly
devastated when the character dies in "Alien
3." However, in the climax of the third movie,
they find themselves unsettled rather than joyous
when Bishop appears to be back from the dead. It
turns out that this isn't Bishop — rather, it's
the man who built him. Known only as "Bishop II,"
this employee of the Weyland-Yutani Corporation
designed the android to look exactly like him.
While the two characters share the same face, they
couldn't be more different. Bishop is willing to
sacrifice himself to save Ripley, while Bishop II
cares only about harvesting the xenomorph inside
of her. Bishop II isn't an android programmed
to carry out the bidding of the company;
he's an actual human being who sees the
xenomorph as a "magnificent specimen."
Bishop II is just as cunning and
callous as Ash from the first movie,
but what makes this man somehow worse is that
you almost want to believe him. How can you not,
when he has Bishop's face? If you rewatch
"Aliens" after seeing this moment from
"Alien 3," you'll never be able to
look at Bishop the same way again.
Norman from "Don't Breathe" certainly seems
like a victim at first glance. After all,
he's just a blind man who comes across as pretty
defenseless after three teenagers break into his
home. Yet, as the movie unfolds, it becomes
increasingly clear that Norman is the villain.
The sequel, "Don't Breathe 2," subverts
expectations once again. Early in the movie,
viewers see the young girl Phoenix running from
Norman's dog. It seems like Phoenix will be
Norman's next victim… until the movie reveals that
Phoenix is actually Norman's adoptive daughter,
and he is simply training her how to survive.
Fans may be surprised to discover that Norman
is actually a protective, albeit icy
dad. It's especially shocking to see
Phoenix be friendly to the dog that
was so terrifying in the original film.
"Snap my fingers, and he'll
bite your testicles off."
Now Norman is shown as less a villain and
more of an antihero. It seems he has moved
away from kidnapping and rape, and has found a
more tasteful way of having a child of his own:
he rescued Phoenix from a fire and
raised her himself. Norman is still
definitely ruthless and terrifying, but he's
not quite the monster he was in the prequel.
It may be difficult for viewers to reconcile these
two sides of Norman. Whether you feel that "Don't
Breathe 2" is humanizing a three-dimensional
character or trying to excuse the actions of
a despicable one, one thing's for sure — it will
completely change how you watch the first film.
Jimmy McGill — more commonly known as Saul Goodman
— may just seem like a crooked lawyer in "Breaking
Bad," but the prequel series "Better Call Saul"
adds a whole new layer to his character. Before
becoming Albuquerque's scummiest attorney, Jimmy
is deeply insecure: he craves approval from his
brother Chuck, a once-great lawyer who never
leaves the house anymore due to his "allergy
to electricity." Even at his lowest, though,
Chuck is still more respected than Jimmy.
But the scene from "Better Call Saul" that
reveals the most about Jimmy is the moment
from the sixth and final season when Kim breaks
up with him. It's especially heartbreaking because
she admits that really she does still love
him — but they can never be together again.
"But we are bad for everyone around
us. Other people suffer because of us."
The breakup is the final straw that
completes Jimmy's transformation into Saul.
Knowing this about Saul, his callous behavior
in "Breaking Bad" is a bit more understandable.
With such a tragic backstory, it's easy
to see why he's willing to sell out his
own clients — like when he urges Walter
to kill Badger in order to save his own
skin. This may also explain why Saul
is flirting with Skylar one minute,
and then telling her he can't imagine how she
and Walter are still married the next. Perhaps
Saul is a bit jealous that Walter managed to
maintain his marriage for as long as he did.
Aside from being a mightily satisfying
payoff for Marvel's Infinity Saga, "Avengers:
Endgame" also enriches the previous films in
the MCU by changing how we view moments from
other movies. The time heist at the center of
the film allows fans to revisit several iconic
MCU scenes alongside their favorite heroes — but
this time, they're seen from different angles.
For instance, the introduction of
"Guardians of the Galaxy's" Peter
Quill is hilariously put in perspective when we
see it through the eyes of Nebula and Rhodey.
"So he's an idiot?"
"Yeah."
Meanwhile, the trip to 2012 New York has
some more surprises in store. Who would
have guessed there would be an epic Captain
America vs. Captain America battle in the
Avengers Tower that was conveniently omitted
from "The Avengers?" In addition, the movie
reminds us that the Hydra-controlled SHIELD had
always been lurking in the background of the MCU.
Perhaps the most head-spinning reveal is that,
after the events of "Endgame," Steve Rogers goes
back in time so he can be reunited with Peggy and
grow old. This means that Peggy Carter's husband,
as mentioned in "The Winter Soldier," is none
other than Cap. The screenwriters of "Avengers:
Endgame" have confirmed that Rogers
was indeed the father of Peggy's kids.
When choosing a villain for the movie "Star Trek
II: The Wrath of Khan," the filmmakers turned to
the original TV series. After defeating the
genetic superman Khan in the episode "Space
Seed," Captain Kirk exiles Khan and his people
to the uninhabited planet Ceti Alpha V. However,
Kirk never bothers to check on them,
so he doesn't realize that Khan ends
up spending a decade and a half in an
uninhabitable wasteland. The sequel
film demonstrates that Kirk's well-meaning
actions can have far-reaching consequences.
The sequel sets a totally different tone from
the original series right from the opening scene,
in which Lieutenant Saavik makes the decision
to rescue the imperiled Kobayashi Maru from
a neutral zone — endangering the entire crew of
the Enterprise. For a moment, it seems like the
Klingons have killed everybody, including Spock
— but a surprise entrance from Kirk reveals that
the whole thing was just a simulation. Although
viewers are relieved to learn that none of what
they just saw was real, the opening sequence shows
fans a darker and more mature version of the "Star
Trek" universe. It's a painful reminder that
the crew of the Enterprise might one day need to
face a "no-win scenario" like the one shown in the
simulation — and that everyone's a redshirt at the
end of the day. Spock actually dies for real later
in the movie — and even though he's resurrected in
the sequels, both his fake and real deaths have
had lasting impacts on the "Star Trek" universe.
A running gag in "The Big Bang Theory"
is the "Roommate Agreement" that has
been established between Sheldon and Leonard.
This is a contract that the two roommates have
signed to spell out what they can and
cannot do while living together — and
Sheldon never hesitates to cite the exact
clauses that he feels Leonard is violating.
"I'm here because you violated our
roommate agreement — specifically,
Section 8: Visitors, Subsection
C: Females, Paragraph 4: Coitus."
A scene from "Young Sheldon" explains where
Sheldon first got this idea as a kid — and it
allows fans to understand why Sheldon cares
so much about contracts into his adulthood.
According to the episode "Vanilla
Ice Cream, Gentleman Callers,
and a Dinette Set," Sheldon's first contract is
created to help his Meemaw while she's dating Dr.
Sturgis. Sheldon can't help but overhear the
two arguing — and he also can't help spying
on them with binoculars. He wants things to
work out between Meemaw and her new boyfriend,
so he offers to draft a relationship contract
so the couple can establish boundaries.
"If this relationship is gonna have any chance
at all, we have to lay down some ground rules."
"Great! I love rules."
"I do too!"
It's a sweet gesture from Sheldon that
shows how much he truly loves his Meemaw.
Of course, this sentimental moment doesn't
hold a candle to a certain other scene from
"The Big Bang Theory" involving Sheldon and his
Meemaw. Fans are sure to find Amy's Christmas
cookie gift extra bittersweet after watching
that particular episode of "Young Sheldon."